hey everybody it's Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 15 king shark versus
Grodd video long live the king there
were so many memes during this episode
too the flash has gotten to the point
where there's enough material that they
can now make fun of themselves using
jokes pulling from season 1 material so
obviously they were a crazy number of
Easter eggs will do a new round of the
flash ring giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment about the episode on the video
obviously spoiler warning for the
episode if you haven't seen it yet but
top 10 WTF and Easter eggs here we go
number 10 they need someone from Earth
to to test the metahuman cure on they
reference earth to Harrison wells
who since the end of season 4 has become
a simple Rick character if you guys are
big Rick and Morty fans if you don't
remember the simple Rick joke it was
just a version of Rick Sanchez I mean it
was sort of a lie within this Rick's
mind but he chose to lead a simple life
just raising his daughter Beth Rick's
mind and the chemical that makes his
brain secrete goes into every simple
Rick's simple wafers wafer cookie that's
kind of what Harrison wells from earth-2
did at the end of season 4 he's like I'm
gonna go be with my daughter Jessie I
don't need to be a crazy genius anymore
so he is now the simple Rick of the
flash universe they do a little arrow
crossover with Lyla because they have to
go to Argus to get king shark because
you all remember this is the earth 2
version of king shark he's the only one
that actually turned into a shark earth
1 king shark was starting to turn into a
shark after the season one particle
accelerator explosion but wound up dying
before that could happen so now they
have his earth one wife or former wife
working with earth two king shark
because it's basically the same person
genetically so they did have a bit of a
romance subplot but if you're okay with
Jaime and Cersei being twins on Game of
Thrones in their relationship then it's
probably okay for her to have a
relationship with the doppelganger not
quite as weird as some of the stuff
that's going on in Game of Thrones right
now number 9 Joe West is back I've
gotten so many questions about this
through the last couple of episodes when
is he coming back they announced it a
little while ago but because they're so
far ahead in the production schedule
episode 15 was the first one that he
filmed when he came back if you don't
know the real reason why he had to leave
the show for a little while it was
because he hurt his back last summer the
act
in real life did something whatever it
was he hurt his back so that is why he
was sitting down for almost every single
scene he was in in the first half of the
season and eventually they just became a
really big thing so they said okay just
go away take a sabbatical heal your back
then when you're all better come back
and you just resume doing episodes like
you normally would so now you have Joe
West walking around just doing normal
things like he would in episodes instead
of having to find creative ways for him
to sit down in all of his scenes the way
the writers on the show explain it
within the context of the episode is
that he actually just took a break to go
heal his body in mind and visit Wally
who's been in Tibet this whole time as
you would expect first episode back they
use him for the iris storyline to help
her get over her trauma from the time
loop episode the punching bag scene
actually reminded me if you remember in
season two I think it was of arrow there
was a shot of felicity
down in the arrow cave punching the
punching bag just like you would see
Sarah or Oliver that season and it was
the most adorable thing ever like she is
the least physically threatening person
that you could possibly have on any of
the DC TV shows if you were to have them
fight kaiju style iris would probably
take her pretty quickly
number eight though the way they
explained rods psychic crown from the
comics I mean it's very big comic book
thing but the way they explained it on
the show is the doctor lambda and was
using it to communicate with King shark
so that he could help treat him because
his mind was slowly regressing to that
of a primal shark in the comics his mind
is a little more balanced like you see
him sitting there reading a book while
he's in prison but he has some of the
primal urges that a shark would have and
the body of a shark Nautilus Labs
obviously a reference to 20,000 Leagues
Under the Sea and what I'm hoping is is
because they used her telepathic crown
to turn into grodd's psychic crown from
the comics I'm hoping that to also turn
cicadas dagger another item from the
show being used for one thing right now
into another big comic book Easter egg
reverse flashes lightning wand from the
Silver Age comics which was again an
easter egg during the Jeff Jones era but
it's mostly a Silver Age thing as you
would expect there were a bunch of Jaws
references they have a couple music cues
when he's approaching the dock for the
first time then six when they try to
reel him back in he goes full jaws
against Cisco Barry preemptively doses
him with the cure they turned that into
a bit of a drama subplot but I thought
the special effects were pretty decent
in terms of flash episodes so first
special effect was obviously him walking
around in broad daylight they've tweaked
his model a little bit they talked about
that before the episode just making
Grodd and King shark look a little bit
better than the last time you saw them
on-screen but also it's a little bit
harder to do the transformation so
that's probably why they dunked him in
the water so they could do that
underwater save a little bit of money
and he comes back out you get the
surprise like he's still kind of
changing back into a human as he flops
onto the dock they have this whole
redemption subplot where he wants to be
held accountable for his actions they're
turning him into more of an antihero
which is important for the end of the
episode too because they leave Grodd in
a really interesting place for the next
time he eventually quote-unquote escapes
five Cisco drops a really funny Oliver
Queen reference don't interrupt a man
when he's trying to brood by himself in
the dark he drops another jaws reference
jaws for the revenge and then for
obviously when Barry comes in to
apologize Grodd emcees both of them he
get this really cool turn made
conversation I like the way that they
pull that off because it's just right
after a Caitlin and Cisco are like
something was messing with his mind and
just as Barry walks and boom Grodd has
him Nora had a couple weird lines of
dialogue where she's like wait a minute
the flash museum has a bunch of stuff
wrong Speed Force doesn't make you
immune to grodd's mind control bears
like he'll know he can totally
mind-control us you better watch the
hell out so I'm curious to see if that's
gonna be a big thing in future episodes
maybe they'll wind up using it for some
big twist during the noir reverse-flash
storyline but it just seemed odd to me
that there would be so much incorrect
information in the flash Museum 3 Barry
and Nora versus Grodd they use a couple
classic moves combos together but moves
that Barry used against Grodd in
previous seasons they used the season 1
supersonic punch move and the one where
he ran around him really fast king shark
offers to become King shark again in
shark form but this time because of the
way they're vibing him package is
permanent so obviously I think it's
important that he stays king shark on
the show I was really upset when I
thought that they might turn him human
permanently there was also really cool
season 2 reference for king shark when
he jumps into battle and says king shark
wants you gone which is just a reference
to the season 2 line zoom wants you dead
which noir also quoted earlier - this
season - and then later said that the
actual battle was way cooler than the
one that she saw in the flash museum -
was actually that quick iris west Joe
west meme
texts at the end of the episode if you
didn't catch it it was a huge Simpsons
reference the gif that iris uses is
actually from The Simpsons it's the food
chain fake infomercial the Troy McClure
did where they're trying to explain the
food chain it's the shark eating the
gorilla but then Joe West memes himself
by saying but Grodd hate banana which is
a reference to season one when Grodd
kidnapped him in the tunnels and he
offered him a banana and grog got really
pissed off with him saying Grodd hate
banana but obviously number one was the
king shark versus Grodd fight pretty
decent special effects from what you'd
expect from a flash episode they
typically have a pretty decent budget
for stuff like this but you never really
sure I think that they had this episode
in mind for a long time so they kind of
knew what they were doing before they
started the episodes because a lot of
this fight between the two of them you
don't actually need to film with actors
on a set because pretty much all this is
special-effects so they can start as
early as they want when they knew that
they were gonna do the episode they said
that they tried to do an episode like
this for a long time but by the time
they would get later in the episodes
they just wouldn't have the money for it
so this year they just planned a little
bit better but the really important
teaser for potential future Grodd versus
king shark stuff is is that obviously
king shark is now permanently a shark
he's still being held in Argos but he's
more of an antihero so they're treating
him a little bit nicer he explains that
because of his shark brain grodd's mind
control abilities don't work on him so
he's a really effective tool against
Grodd and what happened with Grodd is is
they put him in a medically induced coma
but the psychic crown that he was
wearing amplified his ability and is
continuing to grow
so his telepathic abilities will be way
way stronger when he eventually
quote-unquote escapes again which he
probably will in a future season
hopefully they'll find some room for him
in crisis on Infinite Earths because
they're gonna be so much stuff going on
during those episodes hopefully that
explains where they left things so
obviously they're just teasing a rematch
down the road because if Grodd is an
even more powerful telepath then you
need someone who's equally powerful that
can block his abilities and king shark
is the only person that we know that can
do that right now let me know in the
comments what did you guys think about
the king shark vs. Grodd bite or any
other big questions that you had about
the mechanics of everything or anything
else that was going on during the
episode I've got a new Game of Thrones
Season 8 video that I'll post later
tonight look out for that and I'll post
that flash trailer tomorrow morning
that's what I'll name that giveaway
winner from this video so as long as you
have video alerts enabled for my channel
you should see the videos no worries
click here to rewatch the Game of
Thrones season 8 trailer a billion more
times and click here for that god speed
flash season 5 teaser thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]